hi and welcome to movie clips mixology  Oscar edition today for the  oscar-nominated film gravity starring  Sandra Bullock and George Clooney we are  making the anti-gravity cocktail to make  this cocktail here's what you're going  to need lowball glasses  vodka tonic water cranberry juice and a  backlight since there's no ice in this  drink you will need to chill your  ingredients first add two ounces of  vodka  next pour 3 ounces tonic water into the  glass once you've added the tonic water  stir your drink and pour one ounce  cranberry juice now turn on your  blacklight and watch your Galaxy come to  life drink and enjoy responsibly but  don't become detached